9-0 IN THE LINE.
PASTRNAK IN THE SLOT.
MARCHAND, AND OPPORTUNITY, AND
THE PUCK REDIRECTED RIGHT TO
SEGUIN ON TTON
BRUIN PLAYERS COMING BACK, AND
THE PUCK JUST DRIBBLED
THE STARS.
KLINGBERG.
ON THEET THE PUCK.
SOME GUYS GOY IN JUST TO MAKE
CONTACT.
ON FOR
ALEXANDER
PAST THE RIGHTS OUT THERE FOR T
START OF THE SECOND PERIOD.
ON HIS FOREHAND AND PLAY RIGHT
INTO
PATRICE BERGERON DROPS IT OFF,
KLINGBERG IS JUST HAVING ONE OF
THOSE CAMPAIGNS, AND HE BURPS IT
UP GOT
RIPPED FROM THE FAR WALL.
MIGHT HAVAV
THE CAPTAIN JOINSTHAT'S VINTAGE.
FOREHAND
FINAL ATTACK. SETUP.
JOHN KLINGBERG DRAWING EVERYONE
AND THREADS LITTLE
BIT.
KLINGBERG, SO SYRUPY WHEN HETS .
SPOILING THE SHUT-OUT BID FOR
JAKESHOT.
HE BASICALLY PLAYED A LONG GAME
ON THIS ONE ASSAVE.
REBOUND, SET WIDE ON THE TOUCH
FROM NOSEK.YTHING, GIVE UP THE .
AND KLINGBERG PLAYEDFAKSA, BEYO.
PUCK COMES FREE.
SCORE.
SEGUIN HAS ANOTHER.
AND THE STARS EARLIER IN THE
GAME, AND WHAT HAS BEEN FATAL TO
THE
ADMIT, AS HERE'S RADULOV COMING
FREE.
HIS SHOT OVER
THE GLOVE OF SWAYMAN.
VERY DAININ